aber wir sind weit weg die wissen nicht
wo wir sind ja stimmt könnte so ein
spiel
ich habe angst dass die uns kriegen zu
einem weiteren zeigt microsoft hier ja
wieder zusammen im gespann mit luca an
wie es im letztes mal hier gestoppt wo
meine aufnahme auch gestoppt hat nein
also nahm allerdings kommentare nein ihr
habt ja bei mir schon meine zuschauer
schon in der letzten folge gesehen dass
bei mir da ein bisschen was schief
gelaufen ist ja schon erklärt so etwas
ist auch passiert ach so bereiten jetzt
auf den schoko weiter da so ein bisschen
turm finden auf dem ortsnetz alter diese
back to back bei mir auch ein bisschen
jetzt geht's okay also einfach weiter
geradeaus setzen genau bist ja ein turm
finden hier ist an so eine festung
bringt zum beispiel nichts weil wir
brauchen ihr spawn im film obwohl
während kriegen da sauerstoff du kannst
hier
ich habe das match obwohl noch irgendwie
steht wir müssen wieder finden
dabei ist eine geile region aber
irgendwie so mit shader sich das als
wunderschöner alter von wieso ist ein
bisschen sand sollen wir den turm hier
eingehen
genau das ist der erste tour wir
sozusagen roger ist wir fangen von unten
an und arbeite ein sanftes wir sind
sportler wir brauchen das ist ein
skelett bonner der ist unnötig ins
bonner auch unnötig sehr nice ok weiter
nach oben oder unten von unten nach oben
nicht schuldig wir machen
unterschiedliche etagen halt immer so
weiter
von mir aus kann es auch hoch laufen
aber öfter auf keinen fall die vorletzte
kiste oder dem obersten stock betreten
okay bei den boss muss den wir unter
schock so alles lösen kannst du sammelst
ja seelen ich ja wieso nein ich glaube
nicht
nein ich soli vor schluss goalie gemacht
ich hab einen zombie getötet und meine
eigenen hand während der soul start in
skelett getötet während der sol chart
einfach mal in meiner hand ist das heißt
es heißt ja dass sol chart ist jetzt
auch skelett getriggert das heißt ich
muss damit jetzt ist gesetz bonner
abbauarbeiten skelett im opfer ich
wusste ja dass er relativ egal
nur blöd wenn die eliten transport muss
die schießen könnte keine also wie
kannst alles kaputt mache da ist auch
kein zombie drin
nein du hast die kiste geöffnet ich kann
auf die kitze niemals zu greifen euch
den töten den typen ja mach läuft alles
geplündert
ich habe oben glücklicherweise war alles
einsammeln können wir haben einander ist
schielt gefunden ich bin nahezu tot
irgendwie ich jung alt ob die goldene
feder
was ist eigentlich wenn das explodiert
welt und wenn man es oben drin
dann fällt man runter und kriegt schaden
aber wenn man fehler nicht oder
januar aber explosions schauen märz in
japan ist ein skelett ein bisschen angst
du ich packe erst mal ganz kurz die
sachen hier sind hartnäckig für mich ist
das richtig gut ihm irgendwie stören
ich habe vorhin angst gehabt ich hatte
richtig richtig leben verloren er ist
doch echt büro davon ein ende
ich habe alles falsch
das ist zum beispiel zombie hier gewesen
das ist spinne katze mitnehmen
was ja nix zu acht cent weil ich nicht
verzögert wird
so bist du dich verzaubert alter ja ich
hab musste alles mit fahrzeugen sie
alles reparieren muss ich habe zwar
meine lustige von nur 1 prozent deswegen
hat die auch damals abgelegt gehabt also
nur keine skeletts bonner töten
ja die kommentieren sie haben um ein
elektriker für schreiner habe ich doch
so gut ich musste mir mutter auf die
steine also dass ins gesetz bauern auf
jeden fall rein klickt dann ist er weg
so das ist spinne das auch wenn nötig
man ist der tu mir zerfällt alter ja das
ist so ein national power special
das skelett wieder wegkommen wir hier
schon drei skelett sowie am tier 4
die haben richtig glück noch 12 dann
haben wir ein tier 5 und der wird auch
reichen würden also komplett ach so dann
nach ein paar schon eher danach könne
einfach zum beispiel eine festung machen
oder sonst einer spinne zombie ist hier
willkommen nicht dabei du brauchst du
mir ist nur skelett bronze hier oben ist
noch ein skelett ja und vielleicht noch
mehrere also über glück haben ja dass
noch ein skelett habe ich noch mehr
nehmen ist ja gar nicht ob ich oben ist
nichts so eine kiste da sie nicht mal
geile sachen drin
schade davor eine davon ist noch zweiter
kommt eigentlich hin
ok danach können wir daher war eine
festung nämlich gewesen und zwar wenn
wir hier schauen wenn du auf die map
displays das place alte youngster place
place ich hasse blaze farm ich auch
eltern für die türme sind hier auf
hintereinander weg richtig angst
wir singen
aber wenn ich sie mit meinem lied
imagine sport heute kriege ich
allerdings erklären dass noch ein
skelett inc.com bot
alter macht was machen deine seele
eigentlich wie meine seele
wieso da kommen erzählen kästen fax
sorry da noch ein dass noch ein skelett
er was meinst du damit seelen kästen ja
ich habe hier fünf nice also ich hier
bin ich eigentlich schon durch
was meinst mit seinen gästen dinger ja
wenn du die augen ist auch hier ist auch
noch ein skelett jetzt button ich habe
schon alles jetzt muss ich mich hier als
cola oder fliegst du gleiche fläche als
ich verschwende hier mein elektrisch
öffnen und noch mal heftig alter hier
ist alles schon geplündert
hast du hast geplündert ich hab nichts
mitgenommen nahezu leer hier ist echt
nur noch kaffee drin überall so er
wusste wo sollen wir den nächsten
reingehen
ich würde sagen machen wir keine türme
mehr sondern jetzt eine schöne festung
mal die bisher regelmäßig ist oder was
ja ich wünsche wieder unten wo wir
stehen
da ist erstmals chocobos wo sind die
denn hier vorne altlasten orientierung
oder ich finde ich nicht ich werde ich
nicht wo bist du lauf zum alten turm so
weil ich verwende mein ich habe nur noch
23 mal klicken mit meinem electric stuff
und den werde ich nur dafür nutzen wenn
ich zeit runter falle um letzten web man
einmal mit electric sa prächtig macht
man keinen fall schaden ehrlich wer aber
nur kurz vom boden aus nicht deswegen
peterstraße
darum ist ein dass man bewusst
mitgenommen mainz mainz lebt noch und
pink pink da nicht auch ganztägig
deutschen team aber wir sind weit weg
wissen wo wir sind bestimmt für so ein
spiel ist es die uns kriegen wir sind ja
weit weg wenn ja nicht zurück in dieser
folge scheiße das einfach weiter bitte
alter existieren kriegen
okay okay kommt kommt dort gelb größten
pinky
sind statt geld das einfach verarscht wo
bist du ich bin einfach weiter gaal
auskommen immer geradeaus kämpft ihr
wart ihr war schöne festung ich habe
aber angst ist hier und sind daher
kommen diesen 1000 blöcke weit von zu
hause weg ja wenn wir uns irgendwie
kriegen wenn ihnen welche items haben
die es gibt keine items liga wo bist du
hin willst wieder gar ausgeflogen
du bist so da ist eine festung genau
dahin kommt wo unsere kinos am anfang
stand zu weit weg vom nicht bloß 2900 ja
ok 1500 km laufen weg es ist ganz klar
dass ja also ich fliege jetzt ein
bisschen leichter als für dich du ich
muss laufen du bist doch viel schneller
als ich 1500 bin ich und noch 100 blöcke
3000er ich sehe dich ich sehe dich du
bist du allein sowohl das dann richtig
gut denke ich mal reingehen zum eingang
finden ist hier vorne wo packst du hast
du ein problem
ich glaube nicht dass einfach so läuft
noch doch erika 13 von 40 leben hat mein
schogur noch alter anzeige
ganz einfach wird jeder geschmack so
viel cannabis messen so richtig
auskommen das ganze dungeon aber ich
kann ja keine leitern nehmen weil mein
ding nicht geht
kuchen ist auch dabei
wo sind mama ich will hier keiner da
sind ein zombie wo das vielleicht schon
geplündert
ja ich glaube auch er lass mal
weiterfahren hier ist nichts mehr ärgert
ich komme ja die ja ich brauche ich
brauche
wieso beim ein schoko halb tot ist und
das ist so ein schwarzes alter das
kriegt doch was das mir
was ist das mir dass der deutsche von
dass der krippen turm wo bist du denn
genau daneben ist zum christentum oben
diese sportart sagt dirk witten tun wenn
es mich verarschen
es kann nicht jeder palast gottes was so
ein kokon auch trainiert hat ja wo bist
du genau neben dem manchmal gehts hoch
oder kannst du dich fliegende fax ganz
oben
ist das geil und da ist ein boss
fahrtreppen schamane im peter mokaba
nicht viel grund ich habe eine existenz
gefunden ok wo bist du wirst du wie
jetzt unter diesem schatten von diesem
trio ihr euch auch partner von uns hat
ja da bin ich jetzt auch wartet 21 bin
ich hier guck mal da oben weiter um den
schamanen könig weiss ich was
alterklasse scheiße und jetzt wollen
jetzt erweitern davon ist nur eine
festung wollte rausgehen
okay das einfach machen wenn zehn grad
nachts ist das denkmal ist mexikanischer
so blender blümchen also hier vorne sind
hacker aus den gremlins das mit
brennenden bergab ja wenn wir besser
kann mit lang chef und damit diese
kleinen fuchs hier sind die suite die
stehen einfach nur rum und die maro seid
ihr wir sind hinter addiert hinter dir
dir hinter dem joint 7 gratis drauf
gekommen
hier sollte man essenzen fall lassen
alter nicht ihr eure komischen seelen
kacke so wo bist du denn also bist du
eingelaufen schon ja ich töte dir gerade
alle lieder drauf stube wo willst du
denn rein gelaufen
wie kommen wir gar nicht rein ich bin
einfach drauf geflogen pk der gardinger
jetzt auf dem dach zu viel schaden
bekommen weil beleben nur noch
mit angst gerade sollten ist eine
sternschnuppe
er ist jetzt egal also ich glaub ich
dieser turm ist ja die gleich hat gerade
in angst da kam ein paar orte sind sehr
electric ist gefunden
bauermann schade heute darum alle
gefunden um ehrlich zu sein die lag da
schon dass die machen rückstoß alter
schießt ihr habt die machen rückstoß er
ist träger der verfolgt mich so mal ganz
kurz auf seine einsammeln
ich hoffe ich dass der kompost von denen
einem opfer sieht nicht gut aus wie man
überfallen sind wir gerade im untergrund
am reparieren
ein bisschen verarschen schreibt man
jetzt schon ein luca schritt nicht profi
wieder abläuft spiel wieder völlig fit
jetzt jetzt werde ich mir macht mein
schädel aus leute für euch weil egal das
ist dann das ist von boss alter der
macht immer rückstoß ich habe richtig
angst vor dem wo bist du denn
außerdem fallen lassen jetzt erhard
essenzen fallen lassen und crack no
roots ich komme jetzt wieder zu dir oder
die festung
also du siehst mich am arm nahm
ich glaube jetzt hier an einer palisade
lang doch ich sehe dich okay gut ich bin
dann auf seinem dach drauf kommen junge
diese credit suisse alter wieder nicht
dran glauben sie ja weil die kleinen
schützen
winfried so ich glaube wir gerade an
komischen weg runter weil ich da oben
drauf geflogen bin ich das ist sogar
fast alle reisen
ich habe irgendwie angst vor solchen ich
habe vor allem blogs angst hier
irgendwie vorratskeller von dem gefunden
was macht dieser schalter angst ich habe
schalter gedrückt vor allem wir auch
einmal aneinander vorbei die ganze zeit
ich habe angst ich hab ihn schalter
gedrückt sammelst du essenzen ein
bisschen wirklich ich sage ich verfalle
ich mal weg aber naja warum soll das
café mitten in der festung mit in der
festung aber ich habe alle getötet wo
ist schwerer die alle ventile dem tod
retten tötet elektriker sands erwartung
für papa oder was ja das ist jetzt der
meinung gewesen oder jeder basierten
schon drin und wo es unten und seiner
seite eingehen das machen wir ganz viele
warfen mich wenn du nicht kannst ganz
viele trends man richtig viele da sind
eher gut ist wenn die feuer machen dann
wird es hell hier erlebst du mit fackeln
ja ich setze alles voll mit fackeln dass
wir was sehen dürfen die feuer morgen
und warte wie durch sie ist kommt mir
war es schon wichtig davor liegt aber
mich weiter dass ein geheimgang wenn du
nämlich hier sie ist das siehst du dass
dir weiter kannst hier geht's dann
herunter guckt ihr sohn hartmann
was meint ihr wart diesen druckplatten
überall vorsicht
malabo weil diese platten und gäste
richtig drauf weil hier zu verschließen
falle west an draufgegangen
du machst das alles schon da und hier
muss jetzt wirklich vorsichtig sein
wartet diesen druckplatten sohn und der
ist ein boss den du siehst schon
ergreift uns an
also da macht so ein strahl zu mir
siehst du das hier was hier durch die
wand kommt ja da drückt uns weg noch da
dürfen waren noch nicht rein weil der
staat hat mich letztes mal schon mal vor
längerer zeit mal gewann hättet gewann
hättet alter und ich hatte glaube ich
eine starke christian deswegen ab oder
kommen aber gerade wieder doofen wir
können wir so schnitzeln das ist denke
ich nicht mein freund an wo man jetzt
auch noch dran was man auf das jetzt
nicht auch noch irgendwelche sachen sind
wenn ich sehr schön ob ihr druckplatten
sind hier ist knapp
was auch eine falle ne kiste mit sachen
die bomben gefunden
herr über und zdf heftig glaube dich
frei nein ich bin alter nur weil ihr die
pisten still
genau in der lücke gelandet vor dem sv
scherfede wird wieder gestorben
alter ich wollte zu erste hilfe leisten
und ich frei bin der lücke nicht mehr
mein gott als auch mit seinen habe
bomben gefunden ich zeig dir die man
nicht folgen ich finde ich falsch liege
zugucken kann sie rechtsklick mal auf
die also warte ja ich weiß dann kannst
du setzen man die so gut
julian gucken jetzt alles zugenommen ich
kann aber hier auch durchgehende also
redstone sojasauce wir wollen auch
weiter ein
ja genau weil hier ist jetzt der boss ja
und da wollen wir wirklich schon rein
genau die machen mich geschlagen
das ist der boss ist der schamane ja ich
kann ihn nicht ich kann ihn nicht
schlagen musst du hast der kassiert aber
gut wenigstens hat dabei hält mich
festlege rest tod oder heftiges hens
gedroppt egal und er hat das hier
gedroppt hier das ist die geile schott
die einen spieler ziehen kann
das ist eine live ist es also du hast
mir leid für stunts gegeben
kaka ist so rein gehst hier sind noch
weitere kisten und wie geht die treppe
hoch rottersdorf
nämlich nur mit den rest kannst du
willst hier also der war doch schwächer
als ich dachte also immer übel was
rückgängig hier an der seite immer
aufgehen und es ja das ist echt mega
geil wie viel in solchen festes immer so
alles noch dazu kommt dass man so auf
den ersten blick eigentlich gar nicht
sieht das hat sich jemand mit trekstor
mir wirklich aber das ist ja nichts
durch motto oder sowas oder ein plug-in
gemacht und das alles durch rats thomas
ist hinter muss irgendwo ist redstone
sein
genau hier das aktiviert wurde von unten
und immer abdruck sei es nicht richtig
cool umgesetzt richtig richtig gut
gemacht
lag es ja wirklich besser ich liebe dich
ruft gar kein schaden
ehrlich nicht doch ein bisschen machen
die verwirklich wenig also richtig mir
nicht wirklich will mich sonst ist ja
eigentlich nix raus
wir haben auch schon erlitten einige
mädchen um was er nicht wer also das
bonner ist durch wir haben einen dungeon
gemacht dearborn ich gesagt wir müssen
gleich irgendwie mühsal noch finden oder
die ging jetzt in eure richtung rückweg
ja das kann man auch machen die beiden
sind nicht mehr darauf erstmal kurz
rückweg machen ja wir haben jetzt noch
eins oder zwei männer handeln
ich habe die spieler mit also das sind
die sorgen der zeit könnte ich sogar den
rücken vielleicht noch schaffen
ok darf ich vor fliegen ja klar wie man
die richtung hier also aber nur
geradeaus ja was hier sache einfach wenn
du dann zu hause sondern es dauert nicht
mal schlechter schaut ja wir kommen nach
hause mit luca richtig geile produktive
folge hat spaß gemacht wir sind hin und
weg vom dungeon bester sorgen dass
westerwelle ich jetzt doch wie tausend
exil diamonds finden würde
so herrscht im umgang mit ihr unterwegs
einig vergesst die immer noch mal
ägypter angriff viel hektik nimmt sie
gerne ich hab auch so wenig bisher
gesehen auf dieser reise ich hab nur
zwei gesehen oder so ja weil ich ja auf
denke an bis zu dem punkt wo wir die
aufnahme angefangen noch mal angefangen
haben da war wie schon als erfolg gehabt
gut das heißt man kann eigentlich
allgemein relativ wenig sexy karstadt
vorbeigeflogen läuft ehrlich an jedoch
nicht so schnell
ja ich bin auch sofort da menschen bei
diesen coolen gebiet hier wo so
schönwald ist ja geil ich wollte
eigentlich schönen wald ziehen aber dann
wird die blöde weil bekommen hier
wir müssen auch fangen mit einer schönen
fest und es hat noch keiner gut mauern
hat ein krokodil das wird man gerne so
eine burgmauer anfangen zu bauen
das will ich einer schmalen stream
machen aber im stream ist immer nur
krieg da kommt man gar nicht hat ja
immer wenn man sieht dass man stream
kommen die auf den servern töten
deswegen dann kann ich gar kein spiel
wird gerne eine mauer bauen aber ich
glaube jetzt hat man eine kriegsphase
danach wird's wahrscheinlich wieder eine
friedens phase geben weil ich könnte mir
vorstellen dass das jeder stadt zugeht
so komme als habe ich pinky und dass die
kann ich wieder hier schön zurück tun
man wo ich möchte ich dass das fliegen
kann man hole ich mir ein goldenes
chocobo mitchell mit zombie hat er mir
war und dann bei euch reden statt wenn
auch schon da jedoch nicht dass da nicht
nicht so und wir haben jetzt genau die
zeit das zeitkontingent aufgebraucht die
stadt nicht sag mir deinen koordinaten
euch doch ich sehe sieht ja ich bin auch
sofort zu hause ja ich denke schon eine
verabschiedung machen ist auf jeden fall
witzige folge wenn relativ viel erlebt
in der nächsten folge werden uns darum
kümmern dass der sport
im falle dann richtig funktioniert die
folge wird am freitag kommen also am
morgen dementsprechend ne so ist es und
sonst und sonst war alter menton ich
habe angst dass mir ich muss mir nur
kurz mal eine kiste ausstellen weil ich
jetzt alles mal kurz ja mal rein tour
schon provisorisch bevor ich das ein
subtil damit wir diese folge schneller
beenden können
und da würde ich auch sagen leute bleibt
ja ich bin so ich bin noch immer anlass
im spannungsfeld und kann wünschen
sortieren muss ich noch im parken
verfasste doch schon in jungen drauf
stellen sondern der nächsten folge muss
sich schockiert dann und dann werden wir
uns um die opfer kümmern und das ist
meine ausbeute dass hier alles habe ich
bekommen das jetzt nicht so viel aber
wir haben 2007 erfahrung ich kann mir
zum zaubern und in der nächsten folge
machen wir dann die mob alle zusammen
richtigkeit
in der nächsten folge bin ich mitkomme
am aufnehmen na toll macht man im falle
mob falle ist mittwoch fertig mittwoch
das heißt diese folge ist für donnerstag
aber am mittwochabend weil ich an
vorderster linie prüfungen ist sie
fertig also dass die ihr die nutzen
könnt also quasi einen tag nach
weihnachten wie weihnachten
die folge hier kommt doch jetzt also
einen tag an waren nach weihnachten nach
hinten am 18
du bist nur wer eine woche verrutscht am
steam ob alle fertig heft die folge die
wir jetzt hier gerade aufnehmen kommt am
donnerstag online ja dass die siebzehnte
ja und am 18
ist dies nicht der siebzehnte der
donnerstag den 19
ja was der 19 ja und am 18 nämlich für
den 20 und 21 auf rastanlagen weil diese
bei hereinkommt ausland okay da gar
nicht gerade in unserer stadt meine
lieben freunde dann würde ich sagen es
euch gefallen hat lassen bewerten da und
von meiner seite